[Música]
Brasil tendrá que ir a una segunda
vuelta el próximo 30 de octubre para
definir Quién será el nuevo presidente
del gigante suramericano la jornada
electoral en este país transcurrió con
total tranquilidad sin mayores
incidentes y fue un reflejo de un
fenómeno que ya se está volviendo
habitual en América Latina ese
enfrentamiento entre la izquierda y la
derecha ese fenómeno se verá nuevamente
en el balotaje cuando el dos veces
presidente de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva y el actual mandatario Yair
bolsonaro disputen la Silla presidencial
en el Palacio de plan alto así fue como
quedaron entonces las cosas veamos las
cifras ya oficiales del cierre ya con el
99,99% de los votos escrutados según las
cifras que presenta el Tribunal Superior
electoral Así quedó entonces la
repartición de los votos Luis Ignacio
lura da Silva candidato del Petén lideró
la votación con el
48,43% es decir un poco más de 57
millones de votos
en segundo lugar se ubicó el actual
presidente Yair bolsonaro del partido
liberal con el
43.20% es decir un poco más allá de 51
millones de votos algunas de las
reflexiones que podemos decir de esta
jornada antes de entrar al análisis
yairo bolsonaro tuvo un mejor desempeño
en las urnas de lo que se pensaba mejor
de lo que las encuestas también
predecían justamente las encuestas no
acertaron en el análisis y fueron las
grandes perdedoras de la jornada el mapa
de la votación la tendencia del voto por
las regiones también de Juan evidencia
aún más esa polarización que está
viviendo Brasil que también se puede
interpretar por los dos candidatos que
van a ir precisamente a esa segunda
vuelta como les decía es otra vez un
cara a cara entre izquierda y derecha
pero esta jornada electoral va mucho más
allá de la elección presidencial también
había otras selecciones que estaban en
el juego por ejemplo la elección de los
gobernadores estatales también la
elección de diputados un tercio del
senado y asambleas legislativas
regionales veamos
mientras sus seguidores encomendaban a
Dios durante el recuento de votos Yair
bolsonaro obtuvo el domingo pese a su
segundo puesto en la primera vuelta una
importante Victoria Por una parte el
presidente brasileño obtuvo unos
resultados mejores de los que
pronosticaba las encuestas en su carrera
la reelección pero su Victoria
legislativa fue otro de sus grandes
alivios en su cita con las urnas la
nación Sudamericana renovaba los 513
asientos de su cámara de diputados y un
tercio de los 81 escaños del senado el
partido liberal la formación del
ultraderechista logró hacerse con 99
asientos frente a los 80 escaños que
obtuvo la federación de partidos de
izquierda de lulada Silva en el senado
un paisaje semejante con los liberales
de ultraderecha marcando la Pauta con la
mayoría además bolsonaro logró que
figuras polémicas de su entorno lograran
escaños como el exministro de salud
Eduardo pasuelo criticado por su gestión
de la pandemia el ex titular de medio
ambiente Ricardo sales famoso por su
desmantelamiento de los de control
ambiental o Sergio Moro el juez que
encarceló a Lula da Silva las
expectativas del presidente ya eran
altas al inicio de la jornada
expectativa de Victoria hoy teniendo en
cuenta los resultados en un momento
difícil para el país en general y en
estos 45 días de campaña ganamos en
prácticamente todos los estados de
Brasil y los recibimos muy bien pese a
todo las encuestas de cara al balotaje
siguen dando una mayoría al candidato
del partido de los trabajadores que se
comprometió a reforzar su campaña las
próximas semanas
es lo siguiente la lucha continúa hasta
la victoria final Ese es nuestro lema si
lo la gana Eso sí deberá enfrentarse a
un poderoso legislativo opositor que no
se lo pondrá nada fácil un congreso
mayoritariamente ultraconservador blanco
y masculino
la pregunta que está rondando la mente
de muchos brasileños a esta hora es Lula
o bolsonaro por quién votar Cómo se
reparten entonces las cargas de los
candidatos que se quedaron en esta
primera vuelta qué segmento de la
sociedad va a ser definitivo para lograr
el triunfo y Cómo quedará conformado el
congreso lo vamos a analizar hoy aquí en
el debate de France 24 para conversar
sobre este tema saludamos al señor
Leonardo Paz neves él es analista de la
unidad de inteligencia de la fundación
getulio Vargas también es profesor del
departamento de relaciones
internacionales del ivemec College en la
ciudad de Río de Janeiro y aquí en el
estudio de France 24 nos acompaña
Juliana con Lucy ella es periodista
analista y profesora del programa de
periodismo y opinión pública de la
Universidad del Rosario en la ciudad de
Bogotá en Colombia nuestros televidentes
ustedes Recuerden que también hacen
parte de esta conversación dejen sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales ustedes ya saben
estamos en Twitter en Facebook en
instagram no se encuentran como arroba
el debate guión bajo
f24@santilogo que es mi cuenta personal
nuestra etiqueta numeral el debate f24
también rápidamente les recuerdo que
todos los contenidos del programa están
disponibles en Apple podcast podcast en
Spotify deezer y tuning vamos a comenzar
le doy entonces la bienvenida a Leonardo
Leonardo Gracias por estar con nosotros
en el programa bein bingo Punto de
partida pregunta básica para conocer las
posiciones de los invitados su análisis
del panorama de esta segunda vuelta Cómo
van a ser esa repartición de los apoyos
de los candidatos que no pasaron a la
segunda vuelta y si sigue latente entre
los brasileños ese sentimiento de
incertidumbre
Sí así Creo que hay una cierta
incertidumbre porque las personas en
general se fiables las encuestas en las
encuestas como le he dicho fueron las
gran perdedoras creo que la habíará una
división de los votos de Simón y tablets
y distribugomes no creo que van migrar
en todo es para uno otro creo que va a
haber una división pero que creo que
Simón y tablets
si posicionar con Lula Ciro Gómez yo
creo que hay una posibilidad muy grande
de que se declare neutro Pero hay una
posibilidad chiquita En mi opinión de
que va así pues vayas y posicionar con
Lula pero no lo necesito de poco si
logran en tener la misma votación que
tuve una en la primera jornada tiene una
posibilidad muy grande de ganar pero
dicho creo que estoy muy abierto porque
vos sonaro logrado ganar mucho con las
extremas derecha en casi todos los
países entonces
estaba abierto y saludamos aquí en el
estudio a Juliana Juliana bienvenida
Gracias por acompañarnos la misma
pregunta para El Punto de partida Cuál
es el análisis que usted hace general de
esta segunda vuelta apoyos y la
incertidumbre Hola gracias por la
invitación
Pues en partes estoy de acuerdo con
Leonardo pienso que los votos para la
segunda vuelta se va a dividir son más
de 10 millones de votos que tanto Lula
como bozonaron van a tener que disputar
en esa segunda vuelta pero me preocupa
porque el bozonarismo se mostró muy
fuerte porque tuvimos
unas elecciones no solo presenciales
sino que para senado para la cámara
también y con los resultados hemos
podido ver la fuerza que tiene Pues los
partidos conservadores y eso es lo que
me preocupa porque aunque Lula pueda
llegar a ganar la segunda vuelta pues
como va a gobernar no cómo va a ser ese
escenario va a tener gobernabilidad
en Brasil Entonces eso es algo que me
preocupa me preocupa Cómo se ha dado las
votaciones sobre todo en algunos estados
departamentos de Brasil como el Río
Grande del sur San Pablo interiores San
Pablo los interiores Perdón mucho Sobre
todo hacia vosonaro Entonces es una
preocupación que pues ayer cuando fui a
votar a la embajada de Brasil aquí en
Bogotá Pues sí se veía un apoyo mucho
más hacia Lula que que hace abusonaro en
el extranjero ganó Lula pero si hay una
preocupación latente ahí que es hacia
esa derecha esa extrema derecha que ha
ganado más puestos en el senado y en la
cámara es muy preocupante preocupante Y
esa incertidumbre se traslada a
la situación que se está viviendo allí
en el país Leonardo haciendo un poco
retrospectiva de la jornada de ayer
vimos que el presidente bolsonaro tuvo
un mejor desempeño de lo que se esperaba
de acuerdo a las encuestas usted lo
mencionaba también tuvo muy buen
rendimiento en las legislativas Juliana
lo comentaba los partidos de su
tendencia política pues van a tener un
poco más de comodidad en el congreso
brasileño su análisis del desempeño de
bolsonaro en esta jornada pasa en la
segunda posición A esta segunda vuelta
bueno como he dicho en mi opinión está
más bien posicionado y que nos creíamos
hacer unos días atrás
una cosa que pienso que es importante
tener Es que no es más en mi opinión una
una confrontación de izquierda y derecha
es una confrontación de la izquierda y
de las centro izquierda con la extrema
derecha porque la derecha en Brasil ha
sido a diezmado Amén los partidos
tradicionales de la derecha centro
derecha son muy flacos ahora muy son muy
importantes entonces la la que suene
cómo funcionaron vaya a lograr tener
apoyo de los otros de la centro derecha
que está muy flacos ahora para quedar
más fuerza para combatir a la izquierda
lleva siempre izquierda
Julián acá en el estudio de France 24
este buen rendimiento de bolsonaro A qué
se puede deber estaba ahí en juego el
voto de los evangélicos y también se
hablaba mucho el voto de los jóvenes un
gran grueso de los votantes nuevos que
llegaban al padrón electoral eran
jóvenes brasileños que votaban por
primera vez que jugó ahí a favor del
presidente Yo pienso que hay un miedo a
perder Sí para los pobres por así decir
era una clase media clase una élite en
Brasil que tiene miedo a perder para
programas sociales que es pues la la
puesta de Lula Sí entonces mucha gente
pues la clase media tiene un discurso
pues que tienen que trabajar los pobres
tienen que trabajar y que sí no pueden
estar re vagos y en que nosotros nos
está trabajando para ellos Entonces
sienten embolsonado ese apoyo por así
decir que no necesariamente en la
práctica y sociedad pero sí
el discurso vos sonaro tenía un discurso
ideológico muy muy fuerte y que logra
manejar digamos mucha muchos electores
una masa grande en mi opinión y entonces
logra con eso con ese discurso y con un
discurso también contra minorías contra
mujeres consigue imponerse como no en su
masculino por así decir para no hacer
otras palabras entonces logra también
conseguir mucho electorado por ahí
a través de su discurso que es un
discurso Y si llega su comunicación por
redes sociales la comunicación política
que hace llega mucho más allá que la
comunicación que ha hecho el PT entonces
me parece que ahí también influye el
trabaja mucho más en mis redes sociales
el alcance que llega a los jóvenes es
mayor pienso yo que
el candidato Lula Leonardo su opinión
bueno ellos
ha conseguido hacer una cosa muy grande
porque hasta ahora nosotros obteníamos
personas que seguían a los lulistas o
cosas como quiera no teníamos una otra
personaje acá en Brasil que podría crear
un movimiento suyo no hemos visto
repartidología pero momentos soy yo
emocionado Ha logrado en esto ello ha
hecho un movimiento devocionalistas es
una cosa que tenemos que tener en cuenta
cuando vamos a pensar en Cómo
evolucionaron van trabajadas con el
congreso porque
los partidos que es que hoy soportan
bolsonaro y ya hace soportaron a Lula en
su gobierno lo mismo que él lo partido
liberal que está como sonar ahora ha
sido parte de la bases de Luna creo que
Hay una posibilidad de de
lo partido liberal gravitar para más
cerca del lugar y Bueno pero
creo que hay una posibilidad de
evolucionar sacar sus bozonaristas de
estos partidos como ha hecho cuando
partido pecial y que ha sido partiendo
que ha ganado 2018 Entonces tenemos que
tener mucho claro como la composición de
los partidos los partidos que son más
pragmáticos bueno para que matemáticos
ideología y las personas que han del
movimiento emocional revolucionalistas
que esto sí son más ideológicos eso la
cuestión de la composición de la
gobernabilidad en Brasil yo quería
complementar con algo que me parece que
es fundamental parece debate que estamos
teniendo aquí que es lo siguiente es
pensar que tanto Lula como vos sonaron o
incluso la estrategia
ideológica comunicativa y evolucionario
quita
el foco de lo que ha hecho bolsonaro
durante su gobierno y pone a esa su
persona hasta ese personaje que es El
Mesías que es el que puede salvar a
Brasil Entonces eso es muy grave porque
ha habido
digamos su gobierno ha tenido desde un
montón de denuncias de corrupción por
ejemplo el presupuesto hacia la mujer no
todo que era protección de la Mujer
mujer cabeza de hogar violencia contra
la mujer en este año bajo a un tercio de
lo que era en el gobierno de PT sí
Entonces eso no se habla se se pierde de
analizar Cómo ha sido el Gobierno
vosonaro porque está jugando con
ideología con el tema de la familia con
el tema de Dios con el tema de prohibir
el aborto en Brasil que mira la la
izquierda tiene el kit gay y que va a
enseñar sexo no como los niños van a
hacer sexo en en los Colegios entonces
como que cambia el debate hacia un
ataque hacia Lula hacia los gobiernos
anteriores de PT Y entonces claro muchas
veces El lector no no no se da cuenta de
este juego político que hay y de poder y
de ideológico
en un juego en donde se lanzan estos
discursos o muy conservadores O tal vez
muy progresistas y son pocas las
digamos propuestas que han hecho los dos
candidatos que es una de las grandes
deudas de esta campaña la ausencia de
propuestas en los debates de ideas
demostrar un poco Hacia dónde se dirige
el país y cuál es la mentalidad o cuál
es el norte que va a tener Brasil
dependiendo del presidente que tenga
para los próximos años justamente de
Cara a esas a esa segunda vuelta
aquí se le exigirá a los dos candidatos
ya venir a ofrecer a los electores ideas
concretas Qué hacer con situaciones muy
complejas salir adelante económicamente
reposicionar a Brasil a nivel
internacional y estabilizar un poco el
país que se está recuperando después de
la pandemia de Kobe 19 Leonardo
propuestas ejes temáticos puntuales de
la necesidad del país
bueno
desafortunadamente ustedes aciertos no
creo que van a no van a entrar mucho la
gestión de las propuestas concretas a la
creación nos tenemos acá una corrida que
es tribal las personas están acercando
de sus tribus van a discutir intentar en
realidad
a incrementar a la ejercitación
ejercitación de los candidatos entonces
creo que los debates todos los que van a
ver hasta la 30 de octubre será
abusonaro Lula diciendo que al otro
miente
trayendo las que son de corrupción de
una de otro diciendo que un bueno de las
gestiones que
ha apoyado la ha muerto otros que van de
ser que ha llegado de las milicias
Entonces no creo que las propuestas
serán
los centros de los debates en la de la
segunda puerta sí Juliana para hablar
sobre este tema añado que además de
ausencia de propuestas los candidatos
sean atacado constantemente y cada uno
ha hablado es de lo que hizo Lula habla
de lo que hizo en sus dos periodos
pasados como presidente y bolsonaro
también habla de lo que ha hecho como
presidente hasta el momento no han dicho
nada hacia adelante esto en digámoslo en
estrategia política la gente se conforma
con con solamente ver estas discusiones
y nadie le está exigiendo a los
candidatos como si fuera un circo sí
resumidamente es Eso es un circo es una
política de circo porque en el último
debate que hubo el jueves una vergüenza
que había un padre que no era padre que
estaba disfrazado y para conocer no para
dar digamos llamar la atención del
electorado hacia abusonaro entonces uno
entre otras que estaban hay otras
candidatas también que pues intentaban
Llamar el debate para las propuestas Sí
vamos a discutir el Brasil pero también
era un poco actuando no sobreando
entonces ahí también pienso en el
electorado Quién es el electorado
brasileño quien es ese ciudadano que
realmente está pensando yo pienso que no
la mayoría no porque realmente deberían
analizar las propuestas
independientemente de si yo soy de
izquierdas si yo soy de derecha no esa
polarización social y política dejarla a
un lado entonces muy complejo Cuando uno
piensa que sí muchos son estudiados son
profesionales y no son capaces de
analizar un contexto social y político
que estamos viviendo Entonces eso me
parece lo más grave Santiago hay poca
crítica por parte de la sociedad
brasileña algo que se parece a muchos
países de América Latina y también es
parte de ese desconcierto que hay de la
sociedad hacia la clase política que
está gobernando los diferentes países es
un fenómeno que no solamente se presenta
en Brasil Hablemos del escenario para la
segunda vuelta para Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva muchos analistas dicen que tendrá
que coquetear digámoslo así con con el
centro para poder lograr esos votos que
necesita
qué tan importante será ahí su figura
vicepresidencial Gerardo admin será
fundamental para lograr esos votos Cuál
es el análisis que hace usted Leonardo
Bueno creo que Lula ya ha hecho esto
bueno la primer vuelta
Ha logrado intradillar casi todas las
centros la centro izquierda y uno parte
de la centro derecha para su lado creo
que no la tienen tener una gran tarea
ahora de hablar con tablets y su partido
que ha repartido muy muy importante en
una política brasileña
creo que va a intentarse aproximarse a
acercar un poquito más decir Gómez bueno
de la de los electores decir Gómez no
decir Gómez la persona creo que va a
intentar también a lidar con la que son
una distinción fueron como 20% de los
brasileños no votaron son casi 30
millones de personas entonces estás una
patamar histórico normal pero creo que
no la va a intentar a convencer a las
personas a ir en votar en hacer una
vuelta Juliana por este lado que va a
jugarse Lula en estas en estos 30 días
de campaña estoy bastante de acuerdo con
el comentario de Leonardo Además pienso
que de pronto Lula va a intentar
acercarse más a los conservadores del
sur de Brasil aliarse de pronto con
Eduardo leite que es el gobernador está
bueno ahora ya está ahí estaba para
hacer la campaña no era gobernador puede
ser que de ahí consiga votos del
interior de del Sur del país
intentaron poco hacia el interior de San
Pablo porque hay muchos votantes Y es
pues a través de aoking que su bici pues
ahí pues puede intentar conseguir que
ese centro no derecha puede conseguir
más votos Aunque claro alquimin tampoco
es que tenga digamos mucha popularidad
en San Pablo Sí a pesar de ser un
político de allí y tal no está un bien
visto entonces también y y para los que
somos de izquierda Me asumo es guerra
también es rara un poco rara esa esa
Alianza entre aokimin y Lula desde
es estratégica para intentar conseguir
más votos pero claro tampoco es que sea
ahí un gran una garantía sí Lo cierto es
que Lula llega Pues con el favoritismo
haber pasado de primero pero nada está
dicho todo puede pasar el 30 de octubre
ahora veamos al otro candidato A
bolsonaro que llega Yo creo que llega un
poco más fortalecido de lo que esperaba
llegar hasta segunda vuelta con ese
resultado en las legislativas el mismo
asumió esa pérdida de liderazgo de votos
en algunos estados puntuales Como por
ejemplo Minas gerais pero también
destacó el desempeño que hubo en las
legislativas en Santa Catarina que
incluso él dijo que había que ver cómo
se manejaba y se aprovechaba eso de Cara
a esta segunda vuelta comienzo con
Juliana para hacer la ronda la inversa
la perspectiva de lo que puede ser
bolsonaro de las fichas que tiene que
mover a quién le va a coquetear
pues ahí siento que primero va a seguir
una guerra va digamos invertir en esa
guerra ideológica por redes sociales va
a apostar por la desinformación va a
apostar por un discurso de ataque cada
vez más a Lula en esas tres semanas que
quedan
Pues también va a intentar ahí con con
los conservadores mover fichas ya están
en reuniones para para hacerlo no las
alianzas con con sus colegas Y eso pues
yo siento que que esos resultados le
dieron mucha fuerza bolsonaro porque las
encuestas le decían que iba a tener un
33 35% de las intenciones de Voto y
llega a 43 Entonces eso es para él es
Lula pudiera haber ganado quedó a uno
coma seis por ciento de los votos para
ganar en primera vuelta compartible
reforzado y sale Mira yo puedo ganar y
va a apostar toda yo pienso en esa ficha
en la guerra ideológica y que y una
campaña por redes sociales aún más
fortalecida pienso yo que ese va a ser
su gran estrategia vamos a preguntarle a
Leonardo Cuál es la perspectiva que
tiene en torno a la campaña de bolsonaru
Y qué tan fácil puede ser lograr los
apoyos bueno Esto es de acuerdo con
Juliana y creo que son que importantes y
es muy casi para duplicar acá en Brasil
porque estamos diciendo que es una una
briga de dos de dos de dos tribus muy
distintas Pero existe un grupo muy
importante de los lectores de Lula que
también podrían ser los electores de
bolsonaro son personas que ya votaron en
bolsonaron y a votar en ninguna son
personas ingenieras más pobres y muy
conservadoras en las que esto no
esenciales entonces Creo que muchas de
esas personas votaron en esto la primera
ronda pero creo que se evolucionaron
hace una buena estrategia de esa
información de ataques son por la
gestión de de las costumbres creo que
ello Es capaz de cambiar unos votos que
fueron para Lula entonces creo que es Es
una de las más importantes estrategias
porque vamos no tiene muchos lados de
sacar que donde
los votos en la primera ronda
adelante
hoy mismo ya salió las noticias en
Brasil de que bosonaro está anticipando
el último pago de la auxilio Brasil que
es como un beneficio que da a las
personas más pobres sí auxilio gas
también entonces ya como una estrategia
para intentar conquistar votos de esa
población más pobre en Brasil y para
claro antes de la segunda vuelta
entonces adelantó ese pago y ya estaba
jugando prometiendo también que vamos a
dar más beneficios a las mujeres a las
mujeres cabeza de hogar porque sí ha
sido muy criticado bosonaro por haber
dejado sí Ah pues a abandonado por así
la inversión en proyectos hacia la mujer
aunque él dice que no sí para él su
gobierno ha sido maravilloso Esos son
los beneficios de ser presidente y
candidato Al mismo tiempo lo que tiene
que hacer y cumplir como presidente
puede jugar a favor se trata siempre de
jugar a favor para esta candidatura ya
veremos entonces Cómo mueve las fichas
el presidente bolsonaro Lo cierto es que
ha manejado este discurso de El ser el
único capaz de evitar que Brasil se vaya
por ese Abismo Y si todo países como
Argentina Colombia o chile que han dado
un viaje a la izquierda y tratar de
evitar que Brasil vaya por esta misma
Senda lo decía ayer en su intervención
ante unos medios de comunicación allí en
Brasil hablemos de estos de esta tercera
ola de estos partidos de Centro que
lograron votaciones bastante reducidas
pero hubo personajes destacados como
Simone TV que tuvo el 4,16% de los votos
Pese a que su capital pues es reducido
va a ser una pieza importante para esta
segunda vuelta porque el centro no logra
consolidarse en Brasil y qué perfil
había usted a Simone puede empezar a
hacer una carrera consagrarse de pronto
como una figura política destacada así
lo lo mencionan algunos analistas en
Brasil Pues yo siento que tiene
potencial Pero quizás de estar en el
centro En ese momento no es atractivo
hay una polarización entre izquierda y
derecha y que tampoco la izquierda se ha
podido renovar Santiago y por eso pues
ha vuelto Lula no hay una figura de
izquierda fuerte y el centro está ahí
también pues no hay una figura fuerte
para decir mira este viene como o esta
viene con una candidato un candidato a
presidencia de Brasil que realmente
anime al pueblo a decir mira puede ser
una renovación Entonces está en esa
polarización entre izquierda y derecha
pero siento que Simone puede ser Pues
dentro de unos años porque si por lo
menos tiene propuestas más claras ha
intentado en el debate que fue lo que yo
estando a distancia he podido acompañar
Pues todo el debate y sentí que que sí
tiene propuestas pero ahí sabemos
también que ella fue aliada de vosonar
entonces también ahí son cosas que uno
entra a analizar y pesa exactamente
Muchos medios dijeron que fue la única
que llegó con una propuesta Clara su
opinión Leonardo allí en Brasil sobre
esta tercera ola y sobre estos
candidatos que se quedaron en esa
primera fase
perfecto ha sido muy difícil de hacer
una renovación de nuevas personalidades
políticas acá en Brasil Lula En mi
opinión a sacar todo lo oxigeno de las
personas en motores sí Y entonces es muy
difícil el nacimiento de estrellas a la
izquierda a la derecha funcionario bueno
esta esta votación de ayer a mostrando
nosotros que los fenómenos emocionarismo
bueno matado toda la derecha de la
simple derecha en Brasil hasta ahora un
gran personalidades
entonces me creo que surge con una una
posibilidad para años más para frente no
ahora
ella bueno se logró como 4% no es tanto
así pero de una persona que casi no era
conocida en mi país es mucho
en las fiestas está se convirtiendo en
una en la preferida de la familia ahora
los los periodistas los tradicionales
están hablando muy bien de la persona
que bueno que además Llamar atención de
los de los medios de comunicación acá en
Brasil
especialmente porque no tiene mucha
gente es gestión de los Derechos
pero la gestión de de que vaya a tener
una decisión muy difícil ahora porque el
agua dice quedarse sin cargo el senadora
Vais a quedar sin cargo en próximos años
entonces saber cómo vaya así posicionar
para ganar más apoyo y ganar más
visibilidad para los próximos años es
muy difícil muchas personas creen que
parece quedar parece hacer una alianza
con duda e intentar ganar un ministerio
o un cargo en su gobierno otros creen
que haberse ganar más visibilidad
psiquiada en la oposición pero se
encargo entonces hace una decisión muy
difícil que creo que va a ser
fundamental para su futuro
obtuvo 4,16% de los votos eso es 4
millones 915 mil votos que es incluso
mucho más que la población total de
países como Uruguay o algún país
centroamericano es claro estamos
hablando de Brasil donde todo es
exponencialmente más grande que en otros
países de América Latina dos fenómenos
importantes que tuvimos a lo largo de
toda la campaña electoral por supuesto
ayer en esas elecciones generales y que
puede verse también un poco potenciado
digámoslo así de Cara a esa segunda
vuelta y es la polarización que está
viviendo Brasil el mapa electoral
claramente muestra una diferencia entre
norte y sur y también la inseguridad
política muchas personas dicen que les
da miedo comentar sus
tendencias políticas sus afectos
políticos en la calle con la gente en
sus conversaciones del día a día
precisamente por la violencia política
que ha venido viviendo Brasil en los
últimos meses esto de Cara a esa segunda
vuelta lo podemos ver potenciado
Leonardo vamos a hacer la ronda la
inversa Juliana comienzo con Leonardo
Bueno estamos acá trabajando
las gestiones de la violencia
el escenario que nosotros creíamos que
es más probable está segregando ahora
que es de episodios separados de
violencia personas No como no no
movimientos pero personas que con las
nuevas armas que están comprando muchas
armas acá con vosotros va relajado mucho
las políticas de armamento entonces
personas que llevan a hacer brigas
porque zonas de política está con su
arma eh disparan Entonces nosotros
tenemos como cuatro o cinco muertes en
las últimas tres semanas de personas que
han matado por clase Porque zonas
políticas creo que esta esto escenario
vaya a continuar hasta el fin y después
de la de la 30 de octubre porque
y la tensión está muy grande entonces
pero no veo que hasta ahora una
probabilidad muy grande en un movimiento
más grande de violencia sí salvo los
episodios que eso también fue una
incertidumbre que sembró bolsonaro al
desacreditar un poco el funcionamiento
del sistema electoral brasileño y dijo
que no reconocería El Triunfo de otro
candidato sino era él sí Y eso es muy
preocupante también porque es un control
militar lo que proponemos sonar del
sistema electoral porque él no confíe en
la urna electrónica que el mismo apoyó
Sí en los años 90 Pues yo el cambio del
voto en papel a la urna electrónica
Entonces ahora no confía Por qué para
generar esa incertidumbre también y eso
genera Pues en los mismos ciudadanos que
confían los que confían en él Confío en
su palabra Entonces como así la urna
electrónica no es fiable no entonces
genera más digamos incertidumbre y a la
vez puede ser otro motivo no para
discusiones políticas para violencias
políticas y si yo creo respondían a tu
pregunta Santiago que sí puede seguir y
se pueda Grabar en esas tres semanas y
seguir estoy de acuerdo con Leonardo en
eso que puede seguir porque puede sonar
incita la violencia sí al analizar yo
pues hice un trabajo de investigación
analizando los lifes e Instagram de
bolsonaro y Y sí él es como el ciudadano
de bien tiene que ser tiene que poder
autodefenderse la autodefensa es
fundamental y si Nosotros hemos
facilitado la asistencias por armas de
fuego en Brasil entonces hoy el número
no tengo los datos aquí pero subió
muchísimo el número de personas con
licencias de arma de fuego entonces son
legales ellos pueden andar armados
entonces claro ante una discusión lo
mató al otro Sí porque divierge de miedo
logia política o sea no hay libertad y
el Sí aquí hay libertad de expresión
aquí hay libertad de Voto energía
libertad el que quiere tomar vacuna el
que quiere vacunarse se vacuna el que no
no entonces un discurso que va en contra
lo que realmente él hace Incluso el
mismo fue víctima de violencia política
al ser apuñalado en la campaña anterior
en las elecciones pasadas cuando resultó
triunfador y se convirtió en presidente
Ya estoy en el último bloque del
programa hagamos entonces las
conclusiones de lo que nos deja esta
jornada electoral rápidamente Leonardo y
ya de Cara a ese escenario de la segunda
vuelta y le dejo sobre la mesa la
pregunta de oro Leonardo Lula o
bolsonaro
bueno no puede hacer eso porque no tengo
mi certificación de futurólogo Pero creo
que es la es como Luna estás con más
probabilidad creo que tiene una
probabilidad como este tiempo por ciento
de ganar o 65% pero nosotros ayer
creíamos que construir una tenería una
tenería una una larga ventaja
una ronda en una probabilidad muy
chiquita de ganar una primera ronda pero
las encuestas cerraron mucho en favor de
la izquierda entonces a la extrema
derecha hace mostrado más fuerte que
pensábamos y creo que burla tendrá una
voz sonarte generará una fuerza muy
grande en minajeras que son los estados
muy grandes los colegios electorales más
grandes y por este lado Juliana para el
cierre su conclusión y su Apuesta por
sonar o Lula Pues creo que me gustaría
apostar por voz sonar quiero por vos por
Lula quiero pasar por Lula
defiendo ese cambio deseo ese cambio
para Brasil es necesario
hemos perdido mucho en varios aspectos
de la economía en las universidades en
salud pública hemos perdido bastante en
esos cuatro años entonces personalmente
apuesto por Lula pero me preocupa el
hecho de que bolsonaro pues va a sacar
de la manga muchísimas estrategias para
intentar convencer al electorado de que
él es el mejor para gobernar el Brasil
Durante los próximos cuatro años todos
se van a jugar el todo por el todo en
estas elecciones Muchas gracias por
haber estado con nosotros Juliana
Leonardo es todo por hoy En nombre del
equipo técnico les agradezco su sintonía
la producción estuvo a cargo de Laura
garzón y la producción de invitados
estuvo a cargo de Tania Herrera gracias
por su sintonía
[Música]